please be seated everyone
put that one side
good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council
now then we use your procedures if the
fire alarm is activated please vacate
the building via the emergency exits
with respect to felony of the meeting I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured I urge
anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening
any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion the
present public from the meeting
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used or make receive or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
good you'd think I'd know that off by
how hard after four years wouldn't you
anyway agenda item one apologies for
absence I have apologies from counselors
farence Keane razeki and Hopkinson are
there any other apologies
comes with curry
apologies from councilor ARA and
councilor Nixie
thank you any other apologies
councilor Piper
thank you Mr chairman apologies to
encounter Bertie Braidwood
um who's unable to attend and um I'm sad
to report that uh councilor Linda Piper
has a serious dose of man flu so the bad
news is she can't attend this evening Mr
chairman but um there is some good news
it means she's beginning to feel and
understand how I feel when I get it
well there we are that's good
I didn't see you I'm wearing my reading
glasses councilor fellas
councilor Parsons
councilor Parsons thank you
just so that everyone knows I wear my
reading glasses when doing this and so
when I look up I don't automatically see
you I said I'm very Reliant therefore on
uh Democratic services
right agenda item two minutes of the
previous meetings I moved at the minutes
of the council meetings held on the 23rd
of February 2023 be approved and signed
as a correct record with the vice chair
please second second that chair do
members agree
thank you gender item three
announcements I've not been informed of
any announcements however under this
section I would like to say that I would
like to in this end of term meeting
address the council at the end of
council this evening with a few remarks
of my own uh before we wind up so then
moving on to agenda item four
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of Interest this evening
councilor Piper did you
no you're just putting your glasses on
[Laughter]
I did see that much
a gender item five petitions the result
of one petition is being reported to
Council in accordance with council's
petition protocol
that being the case agenda item 5A
responds to the Ramsgate Market petition
the council's response to the petition
is outlined in the report before members
do members have any comment
counselor Aaron um sorry
for someone come in jail I wasn't sure
then
I'll take it you meant me anyway I'll
take that as to you yes chair thank you
um
uh I'm very pleased
that the matter of Ramsgate Market is
now progressing it's been some while
because we've not had the staff to be
able to do it
um and it's stated in the reports I have
met with officer concern and helped as
much as I could to get the thing in
motion
which I'm pleased to see is the only uh
one comment that I would make here
um is that as part of the report it
refers to matters of Kent County Council
in relation to
um road closures
Etc and I would ask and I did mention it
to the officer at the time but I just
would ask that the officer is is advised
that
um
Harbor Street also needs to be included
within those street because it is opened
up until 10 o'clock in the morning so in
which case should the market
become real
um then that would need to be closed
early early morning as well so I'd just
like to make that out thank you chair
thank you Council Auburn I'm sure those
comments were received
roster Austin
could we just
our comms team pleased to put
on the website and to publicize the
response to the petition please because
there's a great deal of concern in
Ramsgate about the length of time this
has taken and it will be encouraging to
people to hear that it is actually
finally progressing thank you
I'm sure that can be taken on board
thank you
no other comments seemingly
I do members therefore agree with the um
Return of the petition
thank you
gender item 8 questions from the press
and Republic and public three questions
have been received from members of the
public in accordance with Council
procedure rule number 13. please note
that only the questioner and respondent
are permitted to speak on the question
could the questioner please only state
the name of the cabinet member to whom
the question is to be put and read out
the exact wording of the question that
they submitted to the council
so straight in therefore to agenda item
6A question number one from a member of
the public regarding Southern water and
housing developments and please welcome
Ms McCourt to the meeting could you
please make your way to the microphone
Ms McCourt
councilor Ashby I've been advised so
your turn game
um
sure is that better
better good okay so this is a question
for councilor Ashby
following the meeting on Tuesday the
14th of March 2023 Tim McMahon from
Southern water explained that whilst
they cannot reject developments he said
that what they and it was quote could do
need to do and try to do is work with
local planning authorities to identify
where constraints are so that they can
be put into their conditions as part of
the developments unquote
how do you know that this occurs for all
housing developments in thanet and
whilst they cannot say no to developers
what is the planning committee at TDC
doing to ensure that southern water is
able to identify any constraints and
advise planning committees before
developments reach approval thank you
thank you very much indeed Ms McCourt
I called upon the leader councilor Ashby
thank you chair thank you
um
utility providers including Southern
water are consulted on all applications
proposing new buildings so they can
comment on the capacity of drainage and
sewage provision and so they can be
recommended any so they can recommend
any required mitigation action
mitigating actions required mitigation
actions would be covered in any planning
consent issue by way of condition I
would also like to add that it is the
duty of the planning committee to ensure
that the correct applications
and proposals Etc and comments from the
agencies are provided so it is a duty of
the planning committee to when called in
to ensure that the relevant
documentation documentation
documentation is in place but also
obviously the documentation is available
to the public so they can make mention
to end and lobby with their local
councilors if they feel that has the the
right
provision hasn't been made so I would
encourage all residents of concern and
also the planning committee to ensure
that the correct procedures are in place
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed Council Ashby
question
number two from a member of the public
regarding listed buildings I'm pleased
to welcome Mr nibb to the meeting Mr
nibb could you make your way to the
microphone please
my question
is for counselor Pugh
and it's concerned the dream and organ
is the grade two listed Cinema organ at
Dreamland in good condition
what records do the council hold
concerning recent inspections
are the current owners being held
responsible for its renovation
and is there an officer in charge whose
remit is the preservation of listed
buildings in thanet
thank you very much Mr nibb I call upon
councilor Pugh to respond
chair and thank you Mr nib for your your
question
field Insight owners are legally
required to protect and maintain listed
structures in their ownership and it is
an offense not to do so the council is
able to investigate alleged breaches of
listed building control and require
specific works or prosecute offenses
where these are identified the council
does not however have the resources to
inspect all listed buildings and
structures in the districts on a routine
basis however we will investigate any
complaints that are raised with our plan
enforcement team I have checked and we
have not received any complaints
concerning the cinema organic Dreamland
but I would say to you Mr nibby if you
are concerned about the organ please
contact me and I'll have offices
investigate it
thank you
thank you Council Pugh
question number three from a member of
the public regarding Community use or
future planning developments so please
welcome Miss Brown to the meeting Mr
Brown could you make your way to the
microphone please
good evening I'm asking this question on
behalf of Westgate and Garland's Action
Group against Housing Development on
farmland and I'm asking this to
counselor
um Ashby again sorry
um what measures our planet District
Council taking to ensure that
conditioners are in place with
developers as part of planning
permission being granted to secure
any schools sorry any schools Health
Centers playgrounds roads Etc are
included in future developments and that
they are up and running for Community
use
thank you Miss Brown I called upon the
leader counselor Ashby to respond
Consulting with the council statutory
Partners about the infrastructure needs
resulting from development
both through the local plan process and
through individual planning applications
the council also negotiates
contributions from developers towards
the cost of these requirements this can
include contributions for health
education transport play and Leisure
provision excuse me during development
the council also collects these
contributions and passes them on to the
relevant agency such as KCC or NHS
England so they can be spent on the
delivery of schools transport health or
other infrastructure
the council will be recruiting an
additional officer and this is good news
for for this particular item that you're
referring to to specifically manage the
collection and monitoring of planning
contributions to ensure that funding is
collected and released when it is due we
will also be reporting on this work
through our annual infrastructure
statement
I'd also like to add that our offices
take a very robust stance on section 106
contributions and take them as far as
they can regarding Provisions for for
amenities so but the good news here is
really that the extra officer helped
that that
the resource that will be put towards
this so it will make it even more robust
so it's good news from thank you for
your question
thank you very much indeed leader uh
moving on now to questions from members
of the council
six questions have been received from
members of the council for this evening
please note that the time allowed for
consideration of questions from Members
shall not exceed 30 minutes I ask
members to be a succinct as possible
therefore gender item 7A question number
one from a member regarding the
refurbishment of the public toilets I
call upon councilor Bailey
thank you chair my questions to cancel a
cup and I'm sorry I'm on my my old
favorite topic of the toilets again
I note that a work tender has gone out
to refurbish the Margate Harbor arm
toilets which is really good news not
Before Time
are there any plans to have any of the
other toilets in the district
refurbished I'm thinking in particular
although not exclusively by any means of
the exterior of the boardstairs harbor
toilets which are a constant eyesore in
a Conservation Area
I know that the community payback team
are willing to paint the outside but
they need the rendering made good first
thank you
thank you councilor Bailey I call upon
counselor cup to respond
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Bailey for your question
um I wish we'd speak about other things
other than just toilets it's just you
need to stop meeting like this
um so a detailed stock condition survey
of public toilet facilities has been
undertaken over the winter period the
findings from this survey work are due
back in the final form next week and
will help inform the new public toilet
strategy details of the strategy
including proposed actions routes to
funding and time scale scale will be
shared after the local elections and I
can confirm that the toilets building at
broadstairs Harbor will be rendered and
painted soon thank you chair yeah good
news councilor couple I call upon
councilor Bailey for a follow-up
question I'd just like to say thank you
very much that was my supplementary
question asking about the update of the
strategy and you've answered it already
so thank you very much
well that's good news
[Laughter]
all right all right question number two
from a member regarding essential
maintenance of The Boundary Park
playground the call upon councilor
Crittenden
thank you
um councilor cup again
um the safety matting under the swings
in the children's playground in the
highly popular Boundary Park has become
worn to the point of dangerous and the
swings have been removed with less than
three months to the start of summer can
you please advise when essential
maintenance will be carried out to the
playground in Boundary Park
thank you councilor Christian counter
cup have you got more good news
thank you chair and thank you coach
Kristen for your question so the safety
matting is regularly inspected as part
of the routine in-house player
inspections and annual external
inspection by rospa which is the Royal
Society for the prevention of accidents
Walter is agreed that the matting is
nearing the end of its useful life it is
not considered to be dangerous at this
Stage IT Remains the plan to undertake
substantial refurbishment projects at
the play area upon receipts of the
funding from the section 106 planning
agreements which have been put in place
for this purpose part of the funding
contribution from Boundary Park has
already been received with a further
funding receipt expected later this year
it is agreed that the decommissioned
swings and matting should be replaced
ahead of the summer season and it is
therefore planned to to carry out this
work within the next two months using
part of the section 106 funding which
has already been received thank you
chair thank you councilor councilor
critten do you have a supplementary
thank you and again once again you have
more or less answered uh all of all of
what my supplementary might have been
because
um
um I am I am actually however concerned
I understand that approximately 12 000
pound of the um section 106 money has
already been received in the bank and it
is good to hear that that is already
about to be spent on what is some fairly
essential maintenance however the rest
of the money is May well be quite some
time away from from what I can gather
um do you have any I any suggestion or
ideas on um when that is likely to be
received and will we as Ward councilors
or whoever is the world counselors be
consulted on the um improvements to
Boundary Park as we were very much a
part of the discussions with the
officers with regard to future plans for
improvements to the park
thank you
thank you cancer criticism councilor Cub
back to you thank you chair and thank
you for your uh further question so on
top of my head I don't know when that
money will come in but I'm more than
happy to talk to officers to find out
and let you know when we are expecting
that money to come in and I think it is
uh important that we do consult with uh
councilors to see what uh we can have
within the park but obviously there are
certain uh parameters that we have to
fit within to make sure that the park is
to cost and also what we can provide and
make sure that is maintained properly
but yes now I'm more than happy to have
further conversations with World
counselors to see what involvement we
can have around that okay thank you
chair
thank you councilor cup
question number three from a member
regarding the funding timetable for the
Margate Town deal I call upon councilor
Curry
thank you chair
my question is for the cabinet member
for economic development counselor
Maurice Pugh as the council is the
accountable body for the Margate Town
deal would you give members an update on
the funding timetable for the selected
projects in the investment plan
particularly the coastal well-being
project in my ward cliftonville West
which not only will develop health
benefits to the local community but also
create new business and Commercial
opportunities for the area
thank you councilor Curry councilor Pugh
thank you chair thank you councilor
Curry for your question
all Town deal projects are to be
delivered by the end of March 2026 with
timelines for some projects still in the
development phase in terms of the
coastal well-being intervention we have
engaged external project managers and
cost consultants for River stages one to
three in relation to the new facilities
at Walker Bay and we are about to
procure an architect team for designs
we've also recently recruited a new
Coastal well-being participation and
skills coordinator who as well as
carrying out stakeholder mapping
engagement and benchmarking will be
developing a participation skills
program around testing New Uses to
promote health and well-being details of
the Town deal projects including
progress and next steps will be kept up
to date on the council's website and I
have a long URL that I'm not going to
read out counselor Curry but I'm more
than happy to send that to you
Curry do you have a supplementary I do
thank you chair given that the original
fund was put in place specifically to
help areas such as cliftonville which
has not yet benefited from the growth
experienced by other more affluent areas
would you agree with me that all the
projects planned for Chris cliftonville
should be a priority for the town deal
ball to implement thank you
back to you cancer pew
thank you councilor Curry for your
supplementary question I think all of
their projects in the town deal needs to
be priority I think that's why they're
in the town deal uh for one
um I disagree particularly with your
point about cliftonville I think we've
seen quite a significant boost and a
buzz around North down Road and and all
of the roads off of that in the area so
I certainly think that some of the buzz
that's kind of in in more Market in the
old town is kind of rubbing off a bit on
cliftonville and I think that's great to
see
um
I think that's that's answer your
question if there's anything else I
haven't really covered please do come to
me after and I'd be happy to uh to sit
down with you and have a chat
thank you counselor Pugh there you are
an open invitation an Open Door
counselor Curry
agenda item 7D question number four from
a member regarding sustainability
assessments for development in thanet I
call upon counselor Smith
thank you chat and this this question is
addressed to the leader
uh given that TDC published the call for
sites Before Christmas uh to include the
site of yet another recent development
application for 95 more homes
um which was described to me by a
Minster resident as a cynical attempt to
Buck the local plan process
this development is proposed just as
public transport services especially in
The Villages are rapidly diminishing at
the same time soaring rents food and
fuel costs are eroding the autonomy of
the community's most vulnerable members
developments like this will add to the
number of unsustainable
codependent population Hobs which will
further transform the surrounding
Villages whose local amenities and
services are already under strain
will TDC undertake a detailed
sustainability approach appraisal of all
such sites in thanet to con consider
access to local Services Access to
Health Care education employment
Healthcare I'm sorry I did say
Healthcare and Leisure facilities
alongside practical transport
connections that can counteract this
trend
thank you councilor Smith's I called
upon the leader councilor Ashby to
respond
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Smith for your question yes the good
news is the answer is yes um I will
elaborate a little bit more than that um
as I've got a couple of minutes uh the
council completed and published a
sustainability appraisal for the sites
allocated in the adopted local plan in
addition an assessment of the impact for
development on allocated sites occurs
within the determination of individual
planning applications
as the review of the local plan
extending the plan period forward from
2031 to 2040 a wholly new sustainability
appraisal will be completed for the
draft proposals including new
development sites proposed
thank you very much leader councilor
Smith do you have a supplementary
question
yeah I do
um
really
um that that isn't the question but
how can it be described as sustainable I
I don't know a presumably many of some
of the members in this room have driven
down Moncton Road in recent times
I don't know whether any of you have
done so without tears I haven't
um but my question is
um
given that housing developers are in the
business of constructing profitably and
it's really only local authorities who
can be expected to build responsibly and
responsively to the communities they
serve in light of recent headlines and
media discussion of the housing crisis
again what pressure can TDC place on
central government to encourage it to
re-establish and develop sustainable
plans sorry for the social housing that
is so badly needed now inflated the
so-called luxury homes with negligible
ecological protections
thank you very much indeed
ah there's one for you leader
um
I actually think I can to be honest um
obviously
your original question was regarding the
sustainability and Appraisal which
obviously there is an answer within that
um but you've expanded it out obviously
social housing
um yes we're all in agreement about
um I would love for this Council to
build all the housing that we need for
all of the people that need housing in
in the area under our own Wing but
obviously that needs requires land and
there we therefore to come to the nub of
the problem where you know one doesn't
meet the other so you've got to find the
balance but as you know the you know
there is ongoing adjustments to the nppf
which isn't hasn't come out yet and we
are forever hopeful as I write
constantly to the government asking for
all of these matters to be taken into
account especially for our the Isle of
thanet because we I I do believe that we
are of special interest here because of
our large volume of agricultural land
and the fact that we're surrounded on
Australia sides by
the Sea and we have a dirty right at the
airport in the middle of it so at the
end of the day I think we do require
special consideration and
um at the 30s in the in the I know
you'll probably write that down right so
I'm just feeding you I'm just feeding
your records
but at the end at the end of the day at
the end of the day we're all fighting
we're all on the same page we're all
fighting the same battle and all I can
say is we all just got to keep fighting
and then hopefully one day the
government will listen whichever
government it may be thank you chair
well you fought your corner well our
leader
agenda item 7e question number five from
a member regarding the cultural
investment fund I call upon counselor
Yates
thank you Joe uh just a question for
Council Pugh it was recently announced
that Morgan Winter Gardens will receive
2.8 million pounds from the 60 million
pound cultural investment fund to
restore their 125 year old theater part
of an announcement there's 70 venues
museums and libraries will receive
monies from this fund uh did TDC make an
application for this fund and if they
did have they received any feedback
feedback as to why we're not successful
and if they didn't make an application
uh why was that thanks
thank you councilor Yates Council Pugh
thank you chair and thank you councilor
Yates for your question I can tell you
uh the council that we did submit an
application to the cultural Development
Fund uh specifically for the theater
Royal
um which was unfortunately unsuccessful
um Arts Council in England do not
um in this case do not provide any
formal feedback on applications that are
unsuccessful so we're not able to to
receive any feedback on that which is
disappointing but unfortunately that's
that's just the way it is
thank you Council appear councilor Yates
I'm sure you've got a supplementary
yes um so according to the council
website
um TDC will host an open day in April
for prospective commercial Partners to
run the Margate Winter Gardens as we're
only a few days away from April is this
still the plan and will we see potential
operators come next month thanks
councilor Pugh back to you
oh thank you Jen thank you Council Yates
uh for your subject supplementary
question I can tell you that yes that is
still the intention
um the entire program that's been set
out uh by this Council for uh for the
Winter Gardens and the entire process to
find a long-term sustainable future for
the Winter Gardens is still on track
um it's still on time
um so we will be continuing with that as
well and what I would add is that
particularly in my time as the cabinet
member for economic development I know
that it's been difficult for residents
and concerning not just for residents
but and councilors on the the future of
the Winter Gardens and we've spoken
about it many times
um in this chamber and at committees and
in private meetings but it's been very
encouraging
um recently to see the level of interest
there are from uh from external parties
and people who are interested in the
Winter Gardens and and the visions that
they have and all of that so it's
incredibly exciting to see
um not just what the future holds for
Winter Gardens but also that it will be
able to hopefully continue to service
the local community and residents in a
very positive way going forward so I'm
very excited to see what happens and I'm
excited although a little bit dismayed
that we haven't finished the process
before the local elections in May I'm
very excited to see um the process
finalized because I think we're really
gonna all be very happy with what
happens to the Winter Gardens so thank
you
thank you Council Pugh and that does
sound promising
a final question from a member of a
member of council regarding the progress
of the Ramsgate Market I call upon
Council wing sorry sounding a bit
repetitive but it chair and thank you
but it just sums up the feeling that
Ramsgate town councilors and and the
Ramsgate TDC councilors have about our
market so it's to councilor Pugh I think
could I please have an update on the
progress to bring back the market to
Ramsgate town center and could this
update also be sent as an email to
Ramsgate Town Council so that key
stakeholders are updated on exactly
where we are at with this very important
matter for our town and thanet
thank you very much indeed uh councilor
Wing I'm I'm reliably informed counselor
Saunders as games will respond this
evening to your question
thank you councilor wing for the
question I'm responding because I'm told
this is part of my portfolio so I feel I
feel obliged as counselor Pugh I know as
Council appears had his fair share I
thought I'd um be able to stick my two
pets in as it were
um frankly the answer that I have in
front of me was covered within the
report
associated with the application for the
petition and the agenda item 5A
so I'm going to bore you for the record
by reading the extract from that report
and then I look forward to your
supplementary so we can put perhaps put
some more meat on the bone so the answer
reads TDC have met with Ramsgate Town
Council and kept them updated on a
regular basis on progress towards
relaunching the market in mid-February
tdc's case officer met with councilor
Steve Alban and Council Auburn has
already elaborated on that on site to
discuss how the market could work going
forward and potential store holder
locations and layout regarding consents
we have established that an updated or
amended planning consent is not required
however an amendment to the traffic
regulation order issued by KCC which
governs access to the High Street King
Street Crete and Queen Street and I'll
make sure that officers are aware that
we need to add Harbor Street to that may
be required specifically in relationship
to access times and of course once we
find an operator it will be the operator
that will do that liaising with King
County Council we are currently in the
process of drafting a specification for
discussion and agreement with our
procurement team with a view to inviting
expressions of Interest a response
regarding the petition submitted to TVC
for the reimbursement of the market has
been sent to the petitioner and a report
outlining the response for information
only has been submitted to the full
council meeting to be held today on the
30th of March March 2023 I rest my case
and wait for the supplementary
thank you councilor Saunders and it's
good to hear you're on top of your
portfolio councilor Wing yes a quick
supplement could you look into your
crystal ball and give give us a
guarantee that perhaps the market will
arrive in 2023 and does this Council
need TDC councilors to give our KCC
counselors a bit of a shove over the
road over the information with the road
closure I don't people find it quite
frustrating because it's not like it's a
new market there was a market there so
that's something residents and
councilors can't really understand that
all those Provisions would have been
there previously and so we're not quite
sure how long why this is taking so long
but we do see it as a key driver for our
town and supporting the small businesses
and also startup businesses for thanet
well thank you councilor Wing I don't
think councilman Saunders will need a
crystal ball because he's on top of his
portfolio
absolutely
um and those who know me know they'll
have a crystal ball sitting on my
mantelpiece
in fact he's got an angel floating
inside so it helps me all the time
um I think you understand from previous
meetings that I'm quite passionate about
getting in the market back myself and
I'm very very disappointed that the
wills of local government do turn very
very slowly not only on this subject but
on other subjects that no doubt had a
future meeting I'll be able to wax
lyrically on but yes I'll make sure that
we do everything possible to get the
procurement team up and running and
looking for an operator at the earliest
possible opportunity
thank you thank you again councilor
Saunders
item eight motions on notice no motions
on notice have been received in
accordance with Council procedure rule
three
the item nine the leaders report call
upon the leader councilor Ashby
thank you chair
it was a great privilege to be elected
as leader of Planet District Council in
June 2021
in my expect sorry acceptance speech I
pledge to do my best along with my
cabinet and group members to deliver
some positive changes by dealing with
the governance issues while seeking to
identify areas where we could encourage
Enterprise and deliver economic growth
when I look back over the past 22 months
firstly my hair was not this gray but
mainly we have gone a long way to
achieving those goals and with the
feeling that the council is now a much
better place and and it gives me a great
sense of pride
this achievement was combined was a
combined effort of members and the
officers who held everything together
during what was a very difficult period
for this Council
my personal thanks go to Chris Blundell
for who took
who took the helm during the storm and
it was one hell of a storm as the deputy
chief executive and to Colin Carmichael
that was persuaded to agree to join us
as our chief executive and steering the
ship into much calmer and productive
Waters We Now find ourselves in
I would like to acknowledge the officers
the group leaders for their support in
matters that required cross-party
consensus and finally a special thanks
to my loyal cabinet for their hard work
following approval at the cabinet
meeting on the 2nd of March I'm
delighted that we have taken a step
closer to seeing a ferry service return
to the port of Ramsgate the procurement
exercise is now started to look for a
commercial operator and as I said in my
press release this is an exciting window
to turn around the fortunes of the port
and to realize the opening is a
commercial Port can provide and a
massive opportunity for the district
the port is a National Asset and we must
and we do have the responsibility to
ensure that we utilize it to its full
potential
the southern water payment of a hundred
thousand pounds which um I don't know if
you remember back in the day I suppose
it's that flashback of me swimming
around Walpole pool but um in
recognition of the water quality issues
experienced in than it will be utilized
for improvements to some of our Coastal
assets this funding will make a
noticeable difference to a number of
projects that we would otherwise have
struggled to fund
the projects include Ramsgate lift
restoration 50 000 pounds is going to
Grant to Ramsgate Town Council
disabled beach access at Viking Bay for
25 000 pounds tidal pool repairs at mini
spay 14 and a half thousand pounds the
iron gate for Margate Clock Tower a
little 500 pounds but it goes a long way
there will also be the king Cipher on
their Charles III site from there for
the coronation
um and Coastal shelter improvements at
Westbrook and Palm Bay ten thousand
pounds we have given our warm and
welcome packs of to 190 Senate
households in fuel poverty in
partnership with social Enterprise Kent
the packs were funded by 30 000 pounds
from UK power networks each pack
contained an electric blanket an air
fryer draft excluders for doors windows
and letterboxes reflector radiator foil
and other cold weather kit with
information to access Support Services
Senate has been awarded the best new
scheme award for 2022 at the best bar
none national awards and that takes a
bit of saying so you don't want to have
visited the bar before you have to say
it this is an acceleration scheme that
helps customers to identify well-run
pubs clubs bars and other businesses
that serve alcohol led by Kent Police
licensing with support from our own
licensing officers
earlier this year a defendant was found
guilty of fly tipping bag waste and
household goods in Chatham passage
Ramsgate on the 2nd of March Seven Oaks
magistrate court ordered that the
defendant pay 380 pounds 85 enforcement
costs and 243 pounds 27 towards cleanup
costs it is important that we continue
to send out the message that Sonic
District Council has a zero tolerance
with fly-tipping offenders
for sale balls have gone out on the
logia building in Westbrook the sale
will provide an opportunity for new
ownership
to introduce fresh ideas and A Renewed
commitment to provide first-class
facility for the community and visitors
I think the Tracy Yemen also made an
announcement so um the whole world knows
about it now so thank you Tracy for
helping our marketing campaign on the
log air building
Sonic tentastic has started and runs
until Sunday the 2nd of April this is to
encourage people to shop in their local
Town centers with events and activities
being organized by local businesses as
well as promoting their 10-pound offers
we are producing a short video to
promote the campaign featuring local
businesses business owners and this will
be shared on our social media
at this point I would like to thank all
the councilors that are hanging up their
boots at the next election for this for
their service is a really tough job
being a counselor and they have to give
up a lot of time to do so for very
little reward and sometimes very little
recognition so my thank to to the
councils that are actually retiring
finally I would also like to wish all
councilors standing for re-election the
very best with their campaign and I mean
that sincerely thank you very much
Council thank you chair thank you very
much indeed leader
for all of that
I call upon counselor Everett comment on
or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report
ing chair I mean the last council
meeting before an election can be quite
a lively and contentious Affair and I
don't think that's the case tonight and
I think the leaders set that tone in a
report and it's only right that I should
follow that zone I thank her for the
advanced copy and I think she's right to
say that the council is in a better
place than it was in June 2021 and I
would also acknowledge the part that she
has played in that but I hope equally
that she would accept that without the
work done under the previous labor
Administration we would not have got to
this point
the choices made in 2022 around the
Senior Management were only available
because of the culmination of a long and
difficult internal process which
established the facts and indeed
resulted directly in one statutory
officer leaving
the decisions of 2022 would not have
been supported by the council without
that process
and we should recognize the substantial
contribution that was made by members
who served on the idsc
like the related topic of birth four and
five which is the subject of a very good
report Elsewhere on this agenda the
issues over the senior management team
have occupied this Council from start to
finish
but we have not divided over these
matters on party lines
perhaps because we all face the common
challenge of covid-19 this has not been
a council in which party of political
differences have often become personal
ones and I think that's a good thing and
I hope it continues after the election
it's also been a council of three
leaders which I think is probably just
as well because if any of us about to
put up for the whole four years I think
we'd have probably driven ourselves
around the bend
as far as cross-party working is
concerned we can also say that the
Revival of Ramsgate Port is something
that the labor Administration set in
progress and the conservative cabinet
has taken forward
whichever of us emerges stronger from
the forthcoming election it's important
for Ramsgate and for thanet that on this
issue at least there is agreement
between the two largest parties in the
chamber at any rate
as for southern water it is of course
positive that some good comes out of
their shameful performance but we
mustn't be distracted from the main
issue which is that this company has
failed planet is failing failure and
will no doubt continue to fail than it
that is a topic which I'm sure the next
Council will want to pick up on
I really welcome the warm and well packs
although like the southern water money
they can be seen as a sticking plaster
against the gaping wounds caused by the
cost of living crisis and austerity
personally I've been struck in recent
weeks by people coming to their doors
having sometimes been wrapped up against
the cold inside their homes which to me
is visible confirmation that many feel
they can't afford to run their Heating
we should all find that unacceptable and
perhaps we do but which of us is
prepared to do something big to change
that
similarly it's no good having a zero
tolerance policy on fly tipping if
people still see it around their
neighborhood every other day that is
going to be far more impactful than any
fine important though that is
but these are perhaps questions for the
campaign Trail rather than for the
leaders tonight the next five weeks will
be about what divides us
but when we come back if we come back
the voters will surely expect us to have
some answers on a personal note I'm less
concerned about the ratio of
conservative and labor members than I am
about to decline in the number of
Charlton athletic supporters in the next
Council I and I should particularly miss
my discussions with Council and Mr and
Mrs Saunders about child now fitting and
if you think this council's been a mess
at times you should get involved with
Charlton and have a look at that
but for those of you who don't return by
choice or otherwise you will know what
you've achieved here whether the public
do or not and I hope that you'll be able
to look back on it with pride
thank you very much indeed councilor
Everett I call upon the leader to
respond
on Monday so um that will really be a
bad fear but um
thank you for that and yes
um there was no question in there per se
but uh thank you for your kind words and
I think we did work well I mean I I
chose not to talk specifically about the
idsc I think the idsc we all lived
together through that and it was a very
difficult time
um but it was essential that we held
strong and it was a very it was very
much a cross-party um committee and it
was difficult but we actually
um came through it and I think um we're
probably all the stronger for it and I
think this council is probably all the
stronger for having to go through it but
I believe we followed absolutely correct
processes and everybody was very
professional and we held it together the
officers held it together and
um I think we've come out stronger the
other side so I think we should all be
proud and give our all ourselves a pat
on the back for that
thank you very much leader I've never
understood this camaraderie over footy
but anyway I called upon Council of
Reverend Piper's comment on or ask
questions in relation to the leader's
comments
Harry Kane uh thank you Mr chairman um
if the rumors are to be believed uh
thank you very much Ada for your report
it is brief but it does as you've shown
contain some very important points I I
won't go over them again except to say
thank you wherever thanks is you for
what you have done for what the
opposition leader has done when you've
worked together to try and get some of
the things that we needed to deal with
uh dealt with
um there's just one thing I would like
to mention I think Senate District
Council has done very well
Distributing monies either government or
private sector Distributing money to the
right people not only through the covid
period when they had to distribute money
and assistance but beyond the covid
period as well this has got to have
taken a great many officer hours and has
helped to Great many people and I think
that certainly the the officer team as
well as the the guidance from from
cabinet should be very proud of that and
I've no doubt the council will continue
to do that so long as such help is
available
uh it is always distressing to see when
people's land has been blighted with fly
tipping and right at the beginning there
were Walling shots across the bow that
various changes to the tip run system
would lead to an increase in fly tipping
and so on I guess you can't really
legislate for people who will just tip
rubbish wherever they want to
however if I may comment on the tip
situation I personally have found the
ability to make an appointment and turn
up at the tip to have been a really good
change to the way that system works not
only do we not have endless queues of
traffic down the road but you can go in
dispose of your waste and pull out again
fairly quickly
having said that I do manage the online
booking system very well I just wonder
whether everybody in thanet is able to
do that and understand it because it
does rather send you around the houses
quite a bit and I'm just wondering are
there going to be any other plans to
have any other ways where people can
book a tip run either by phone or a
simple email or a letter indeed to the
council for that
um I finally I would also like to thank
all my colleagues it's been a pleasure
working with you all for the last four
years but I'd like to thank my
colleagues in particular who have stood
by us as a group and we've felt that we
have been impartial in the sense of
supporting both of the administrations
where we thought they were doing the
right thing and perhaps opposing and
objecting where we thought we weren't
quite in tune with that but I want to
thank my colleagues for doing that and
wish everyone
every success if they are campaign to be
re-elected and a final word for our
chairman four years sitting in that seat
is not an easy thing at all we can see
what it's done to his eyesight but thank
you Mr chairman thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Piper I call upon the leader to respond
not just eyesight but look he's lost all
his hair as well so mine's gone gray but
he's obviously chair you have a bigger
problem than that anyway
um
I'll start with the distribution of
funds quite interesting you should say
that because the government are all you
know when they've got these funds oh
look we're giving all these funds and
we're helping everyone but what they
don't then say is that we're going to
pass this burden of distribution onto to
to the local Authority I mean I don't
think that the government central
government give as much respect to local
authorities as they anywhere near what
they should do and they and they often
treat us like I don't know what do they
treat us like a necessary evil I suppose
could could be say
um so I think more recognition should
come from that because the covid
especially and the accounts team I mean
absolutely tremendous work that they did
with that and basically kept everybody
alive be by by sending out the the funds
that they needed to send out
um so you know a little bit more
recognition whatever government it may
be is that their local authorities are
the foot soldiers we are the foot
soldiers for anything that they want to
do they don't actually do the Hands-On
work we have to do it and
um I'm not I could be wrong in saying
this but I don't believe they actually
supplied any funds to us to actually
uh to actually distribute the funds so
um
well maybe after the event so
um I think uh the more we should we
should be saying to the government you
know we are really important to you and
you should really give us a little bit
more recognition so
um the other point is
um on the KCC
um I'm afraid you're going to have to
take that out with your KCC
Representatives on the tip because the
tip is KCC run and it is their website
yes it is a clunky our website nowhere
near as good as our fantastic website
that is run by our comms team so maybe
we can sell maybe we can sell our comms
team to KCC and do the work for them but
yes it is a clunky old site and I would
agree with you thank you chair
thank you very much and the leader I I
just uh that thanks for that but I would
just mention that in all seriousness I
have actually had an invasive operation
on my right eye and I'm still waiting
for the site to fully recover so it's
not an excuse but it is actually a
reason why I do suffer with it finally I
call upon counselor Garner to comment on
or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report
thank you chair I'm over here thank you
oh had this last council meeting before
the election I'd like to start by
thanking the leader for her hard work
since she took over a couple of years
ago I think we can all agree it was a
difficult time to take over and and that
we're in a better place now than we were
then
I'd also like to join her in thanking
Chris Blundell
Colin Carmichael and all staff have
worked hard to improve the governance of
the council
although we certainly are in a much
better place there's still work to do as
highlighted in the recent reviews on the
IMO recommendations and the burst for
five debacle which are on the agenda
later in the evening
the new Council in May however it's
constituted we'll need to continue the
process learn the lessons step up to
their responsibilities and maintain
vigilance to get our TDC to where it
needs to be in an open and transparent
way that engages and takes our residence
with it
our concerns about the proposed new
ferry service at Ramsgate were made
clear at the cabinet meeting where they
were approved
this is a major decision for Ramsgate
which feels like it has been not been
fully thought through
we of course welcome the fact that the
hundred thousand receiving Southern
water is going to be spent on several
projects around thanet I'm particularly
pleased that the improvements to Viking
Bay will will mean access is available
from both sides of the Bay
Southern water though as councilor ever
alluded to
have got off lightly for the devastation
they've caused in the past which we know
is not improving in fact nationally
sewage releases have more than doubled
over the last year and Southern water
are responsible for half of them
as mentioned earlier by Ms McCourt Tim
McMann Southern Waters director of water
operations made it clear at the last
overview in scrutiny panel meeting that
they would be happy to become a
statutory consultant in the planning
process and provide more detailed
information for larger planning
applications and the new Council in May
should take them up on this offer so
that we are more informed when taking
planning decisions which could continue
to do irreversible damage to our
environment
it was good to hear a number of other
positive updates from you in your report
and I'd like to finish by joining you in
Wishing all council is standing for
re-election and all other candidates the
best in their campaigning I hope we can
all focus on ideas that address the
concerns of our residents Safe Streets
good environmental strategies to prevent
littering pollution and anti-social
behavior and support for those in our
communities whom the current cost of
living crisis is making their lives more
difficult than it should be
we look forward to the campaign ahead
well there's a challenge thank you very
much Lee Catholic honor leader of your
response thank you chair
for your response to my report
um
[Music]
something I've read was quite
interesting I think it came out
yesterday or the day before it's not
Southern water but it's one of the water
companies in this part of the world and
they're looking at introducing
um
water tariffs that basically you get the
first 25
000 liters free and then it goes up to
150 for the next per thousand liters up
to a certain amount and then once it
gets past that amount then it really
Rockets through the roof because without
doubt the main problem we have is that
we can the southern water copes with
everything until such times as we have a
storm and as we know we've had quite a
lot of torrential
downpours over the last few years which
has actually caused with with some
obviously failures a lack of
infrastructure Etc so
although we do blame them and they are
to blame we can also be responsible
ourselves and so you know people it
would be good if everybody sort of looks
at this and you know we try and have
this challenge of 100 100 a day which is
uh you know is achievable it's quite
tough but you have to think about things
but also you know have we all got a
barrel in our water bar in our garden
have we got one have we got two you know
because uh
well that's that's right so calves are
soldiers is well of that so I think you
know they are at full and they are
causing problems but we can actually
demonstrate that actually we are the
good guys because we're doing all of
this stuff and you're still screwing up
and you know you've got to sort out your
infrastructure but um that was just an
interesting article that I ran because I
that I read because I know that the
water issue is a the southern water
issue is a big problem here
um thank you for all your other com I
think it's been a really enjoyable
few months and it's quite nice to
actually have a relaxed atmosphere that
we have now it was quite tense when I
first became leader and it was very
daunting I must say it's quite
it is very daunting to stand in in this
spot and you never really know these
questions are quite I think the leader's
report is quite hard because you know I
can sit here and and research my but I
never really know what's coming back at
me and sometimes it's really hard to
sort of just think on your seat and
think you know that you should know the
answer but sometimes you don't but I
thank you all for every for all all the
hard work all counselors for their hard
work and again wish everyone the best of
luck at the election not too much like
mine but the best of luck
thank you very much indeed leader gender
item 10 annual report of the chair of
the overview and scrutiny panel I call
upon counselor Reverend Piper to present
his report
thank you Mr chairman
um those of you have had a chance to
look at the report already will see that
it is quite lengthy which is one of the
reasons why I really do need to thank
all the members of the overview and
scrutiny panel who've been working uh
particularly in the last couple of years
since I took over as the chair of the
panel but some of this work was going on
beforehand before I took over the chair
we have a number of projects that have
been reviewed that have been looked at
most of them have been completed
um I've put my hand up and say the uh
working party that I was involved with
in terms of the memorial plaques and
monuments within our district that has
not produced its final report yet but
I'll immediately throw the blame at the
government we were waiting for distinct
and specific guidelines from the
government for what we should do with
these things but we've had a number of
interesting topics that have come up the
have worked very very hard the coastal
review for example was just one but
there have been a number of panel
projects that everyone's worked very
hard on and as I say I would like to
thank everybody for doing that I commend
the report and the activities of the
committee on all the things that they
have been doing on your behalf so thank
you Mr chairman uh that this I commend
the report here
thank you very much indeed Council Piper
do members have any comments
no
thank you therefore annual report of the
chair of the standards committee under
our agenda item 11.
good evening chair and members of the
council I give to you my annual report
for the year
2223 and it's pleasing to say that of
all the complaints we've had made none
of them have yet been referred to any
investigations so it's saved in the
council some finances and with the
Advent of the local elections come in
new members will need to be advised
about the work of the standards
committee also the code of conduct and
the Declarations of Interest you've all
seen the report
if there's anybody got any questions I'm
quite happy to take them and all I want
to say really is to thank the officers
and members of democratic Services the
members of the standards committee for
their dedication including the
independent members I'd also like to
thank the independent independent person
for the work he undertook and one final
thing counts forever if we want to
change your Allegiance come to Preston
North End
thank you
thank you very much indeed Mr Tucker uh
does anybody have any comments or
questions with Mr Tucker
and I don't see anyone you're off the
hook Mr Tucker thank you very much and
deed for your report
agenda item 12 the annual report of the
chair of the government and audit
committee I call upon councilor Boyd to
present her report
thank you chair and hello everybody
um hopefully you received the report
within your agenda packs this report
provides an overview of the governance
and audit committee's activity during a
municipal year
2022-23 I am pleased to report that the
committee continues to charge its
responsibilities to provide independent
Assurance on the adequacy of the
council's risk management framework and
the associated control environment and
provides robust scrutiny and challenge
of the Authority's financial performance
as outlined in the body of this report
the community has been actively engaged
with both internal and external audit
and I would like to thank all members
who have served on the committee during
the 2022-23 year my thanks also goes to
the council officers who have supported
me in my role as chair and the work of
the committee I recommend the report
thank you very much the councilor Boyd
do members have any questions or
comments on councilor boy's report
I don't see any
thank you very much agenda item 13
independent review of birth four and
five project I call upon the leader
councilor Ashby
thank you chair
a review of birth 4-5 project has been
undertaken on the recommendations of the
independent monitoring officer the
review was undertaken by East Kent audit
partnership and I would like to thank
Christine Parker the head of internal
audit for her detailed and thorough
review of this project
whilst the detailed management response
is still to be formed the corporate
management team has accepted all nine
recommendations that have been made and
intends to embed them in their in our
overall ways of working and specifically
into delivery of major projects
I have every confidence that the council
will learn from this review and
successfully deliver the exciting
projects we have coming up over the next
few years
I would ask Council to note the report
thank you chair
thank you leader Do you have a seconder
council bayford do members agree
thank you very much indeed agenda item
14 implementation of the recommendations
of the external auditor and independent
monitoring officer
no wait a minute no where have we gone
wrong here
your point of order yes who's that
councilor Gardner yes
we've um yeah we've we've nodded through
that report wasn't there shouldn't there
be an opportunity for members to make
comment on it before we do that
well you can by all means I just didn't
see any indication but then again that's
probably my thought councilor Garner
would you like to say anything with
respect to the report no I wouldn't but
my colleagues would
well no wonder I didn't see anything
which of your colleagues would councilor
Wing counselor Wing uh obviously I
attended the cabinet meeting and asked a
number of questions in relation to to
the report and I first of all like to
thank uh Mike Mike cumber for for
speedily responding to those questions
and I would kindly ask that though the
answer to those questions is made public
my name doesn't have to be attached to
the questions I don't need to be the
asker of the questions but I do think
they were questions that needed to be
asked be answered and I did I just would
like to uh re stress the comment I made
the final comment I made about the you
know this this we were aware we were
aware because this is a shared
responsibility for the mess we got into
with the pontoons we were aware that an
environmental impact assessment was
required in 2015 and I just want to say
that I know there was some uh baggage
between residents some councilors and
officers but you know those people are
exonerated because we knew in 2050 we
now know in 2015 that that an
environmental impact impact assessment
was required and that caused the delay
and somewhat of an overspend as clearly
as indicated in that report I just
wanted to make that in that statement in
public because I know there are
residents that were quite offended by by
being uh
by being uh rebuffed if you like uh and
they knew they they were in the right
but I also know that it was very hard
for officers as well so I'm glad the
reports out there I'm glad we can all we
can all move forward we can take on
board the points that were made in that
report and hopefully make a a better
fist of of what's going to happen now on
the pool I would just like to ask one
question though would would would would
the leader make public the project
management team because that was a
crucial part of uh the problems that
arose with the pontoons according to the
review and I think it would be uh only
only rights that residents knew who that
project team was uh it I think it needs
Financial people experts in the field
and that would help residents be
reassured that the right people are
involved in the project thank you
thank you very much any councilor Wing
it's quite a lot to deal with I'm sure
by the leader but now that the other
thing I've mentioned is it's normal
practice to stand when addressing
counsel I didn't want to interrupt you
in full swing but for anybody else you
might want to speak
um does the lead have anything she'd
like to say
yeah I believe there was a question
there um so firstly
um no problem the answers uh
might humber's responses can be
published to all members of the council
that is not an issue
the issue regarding the um I will take
advice from the monitoring officer and I
will come back to you on that I would
imagine the answer is going to be no um
if it was down to me I would still say
no because you know officers are
employed to do operational matters and I
would imagine there were quite a lot of
officers involved in it and I don't
think we need any more witch hunts in
this Council I think the days have gone
of that and we need to draw a line and
move on this report concludes the matter
this is what the internal Lord is who is
a very skilled and and has done a very
thorough and concise report on the birth
four or five project and this now is a
Lessons Learned report and going there's
no point looking backwards we need to
look forward to make sure that that the
errors aren't made again so I don't
think there's any benefit into looking
backwards and but I will check with the
monitoring officer and with the chief
executive but if it's down to me then I
would say know because I don't see any
point in looking backwards I only ever
look forwards and I hope that everybody
else in the council does as well thank
you
thank you very much
um I'll move on now to councilor Austin
thank you chair I don't think we were
suggesting about looking backwards at
all but equally I think it's quite clear
from this report that the matter is not
concluded we have a number of lessons
that we need to learn going forward and
this report and the one that we're going
to discuss in a minute have both arrived
at a time obviously a flux when we're
just approaching local elections is
crucial that we keep the momentum up to
improve our governance to improve our
project management to ensure that we are
publicizing what we're doing and being
as transparent as we possibly can both
within the council and with members of
the public and that we know that didn't
work very well in this project we must
learn the lessons particularly with
regards to other development support
there's a lot of exciting possibilities
but there's also a many a slip situation
and we need to be quite sure that we've
covered all those eventualities and we
need to be quite sure that we are are
sharing information both amongst
ourselves or amongst the future Council
and with residents as far as we possibly
can so yes I accept We're Not Looking
Back except to learn the lessons please
and to not repeat them in the future
thank you
thank you very much and the councilor
Austin I do think the leader wanted to
say anymore that
oh does she
no no I don't think I have any more
comment uh anybody who wants to say any
more on this this evening so I think
we'll move on to agenda item 14 The
implementation of the recommendations of
the external auditor at the independent
monitoring officer
I call upon the leader
learning my corn tonight chair and
chair on today
soon after I became leader in summer
2021 the external auditor produced the
report into our council's government's
Arrangements
the conclusions reached were not
comfortable for us highlighting as they
did significant disruption in Council
officer relationships as well as being
between senior officers and the need to
thoroughly review our staffing
procedures
the fundamental recommendation from the
Auditors was that we should commission a
report from an independent monitoring
officer from another larger Council
Council who would look into these issues
more thoroughly we appointed Quinton
Baker from herefordshire County Council
who worked very closely with myself and
produced his report in May 2022
since then Mr Baker's report has been
considered by Council and the
recommendations approved
the previous statutory officers have
left the council and we have appointed
new officers to take on those positions
as leader I have worked with those
officers to ensure that all the all the
failings identified in each report have
been addressed and the recommendations
implemented
I am pleased that the interim chief
executive and I were able to report to
cabinet and now to council
that apart from the longer term issues
which are for the next Council to be to
consider the recommendations have been
implemented I would ask Council to note
the report thank you chair
thank you very much Lee did you have a
seconder
councilor bayford
Council Austin yes I see you this time
thank you chair
um I just want to say the same as I said
at the cabinet meeting which is it's
really encouraging to see the progress
that we have made
um since the uh
events of last year and uh I'd like to
thank the leader again for her efforts
in that regard however I was very
worried to see that certain things had
been ticked off uh in the action plan
for the report that I don't feel are
ready to be ticked off yet uh
specifically and I know councilor Alvin
highlighted this at the cabinet meeting
back bench counselors do not always get
the information they need to be able to
keep their residents informed or indeed
take an active part in discussions at
meetings like this I do appreciate that
much of that is down to staff capacity
but I do think there is also a matter of
attitude and experience that some of
those staff have had in understanding
the role of members so my question is
when we are looking at our Splendid new
training program for new members are we
also going to ensure that office as both
existing and new offices are receiving a
similar sort of training about how they
relate to members and how members should
relate to them thank you
thank you very much councilor afternoon
would you like have you got a response
later
of course you never know me to be quiet
on anything have you
um the chief executive and the head of
democratic services to take that all
into account and I would assume and I
have assumed that that is already built
into the program
so I think you know you need not fear
new councilors old counselors new
officers old officers will all be
briefed on how we are to communicate
going forward I think the communications
are a million times better than they
ever were before and I have every
confidence with the chief executive's
new structure that he's put together and
when all the posts are filled you'll
have more information than you probably
want to receive because you'll be
reading it all day and all night so I
certainly receive a lot of information
that takes up a large amount of reading
but no I take your point on board and
I'm sure it's noted in the minutes and
it's noted by the relevant officers that
can Implement that in the new term thank
you
thank you very much indeed leader
two members agree
thank you
and gender item 13 changes to committees
panels and Boards
2022-2023 proportionality I call upon
the leader to make a proposal in respect
of the options as outlined in the report
[Applause]
I request option two
councilor bayford does any member wish
to propose an alternative option
I don't see anybody indicating so do
members agree with that proposal
thank you
well we know
sorry again my you know it's just as
well I did herself with my eyesight at
the beginning of my term of office isn't
it
nomination of members to serve on
committees
group leaders may wish to take the
opportunity to advise or change their
nominations to committees panels and
boards for the remainder of the
2022-2023 term
councilor Ashby do you wish to advise of
any nomination changes
no thank you
thank you forever do you wish to advise
of any nomination changes tempting
though it is clear now
good sense of humor councilor Garner do
you wish to advise of any nomination
changes
no thank you
[Applause]
cancer relevant Stuart Piper do you wish
to advise of any nomination changes
this
thank you chair
well I've sorted that out thank you very
much indeed members now look I would
finish off with just a few words since
it's the
few words since we're at the end of this
term
so if I can read what I've got to say
here as you're aware this is the last
full Council of this term ahead of
Elections on the 4th of May and I shall
just say a few words in conclusion as
your chair
I'm not going to draw any attention to
problem solved or left unsolved or
failures and or any successes during the
last four years tenure of this Council
as chairman mine has been a
non-political role
nor will I highlight any shall I say
colorful issues as Ricky Gervais at the
Oscars would have done
although this might be disappointing
it's not my way
what I will say is that I believe we
have together as a council performed
incredibly well under the most difficult
of circumstances
this has been an unusually difficult
term with the Covey pandemic forcing
social distancing at our meetings here
in the council chamber the Ramsgate
Sports Center the Winter Gardens and
many Meetings online it has been a
difficult time for all of us and for
myself I have found the different venues
and locations quite stressful
[Music]
of you may wonder what it's like to be
up here for close on two hours on a
Thursday evening
well you see and feel everything as
different counselors stand to speak you
feel their determination to put a point
across their fears and anxieties their
frustrations and embarrassments and you
empathize
emotionally it's exhausting once home I
need a stiff drink to get over it
I'm quite serious
no
thank you councilor bayford
the reason I mentioned this is to draw
all of your attention to something to
which I have become more and more aware
that over time all of you became less
political Rivals are more like
colleagues
with the same agenda to the to do the
best for the people of thanet we all are
here to serve
some of those who were the biggest
adversaries in this chamber are now dare
I say more than colleagues but perhaps
even friends
I would also like to pay tribute to the
officers and staff of the council not
least Democratic services without who
support my role would not be possible
councilor 20 years ago
it never occurred to me at the start how
long I will be here on deed that I would
leave after chairing the council for
four years close in fact to a record
in fact it is frightening how fast those
20 years have passed
but time is now up
some of you may know that I've been
deselected as a candidate for not being
conservative enough
I'm not quite sure I know how to respond
to that
well my feelings are that it's time
anyway to attend to a whole bucket list
of holidays Ann and I have put on hold
for too long
nevertheless and in closing I shall miss
all of you not least because you're all
actually rather a good lot
so good evening nice to have known you
and it's time to move on
and I here with call the meeting to a
close
it is a tough old job up there isn't it
and you do take a we do review a little
bit don't we and you do take it all in
very good spirit so I'd like to thank
you yes
um long time long service there and you
are the figurehead of the council and I
thank you for all your work and uh that
you have done for the council over these
years thank you
I appreciate that thank you very much
[Applause]